It turns out that we also need a component that's going to supply us the text.
Now, this isn't strictly in the GUI toolkit. But
in order to make this thing work, we have to access the text somehow. So we'll
call that the file manager component. We're going to make some assumptions.
We're going to assume that you cannot hold the entire files contents in memory.
You're going to have to go to the disk to get it. And assuming you have at
the operating level line oriented access to the file. So in your,
in your system libraries you have a way of, of reading the lines at anytime.
So you're going to need to have a module, that when requested can
retrieve a limited length, consecutive sequence of the file's lines.
And we're also going to assume we don't have to worry about opening the file or
closing the file. Just the reading of the file, supplying the lines.